ne vous fiez pas à cette porte fermée
pendant le confinement
les travaux de l'assemblée ont continué
au ralenti puisqu'une poignée de députés
seulement ont eu le droit de siéger pour
voter les textes les plus urgents dans
un hémicycle clairsemé
je salue bien sûr tous nos collègues
dont l'absence physique ne doit pas
masquer le travail actif et la présence
à distance
[Musique]
pour les autres députés privé
d'assembler le confinement s'est passé
ailleurs dans leur circonscription
confiné des actifs
voici un député qui a renfilé hop pur
blues sa tenue de médecins elle a repris
à plein temps dans sa pharmacie
[Musique]
y a pas de base celui ci s'est improvisé
livreur bon allez on est partis livreur
de gel hydroalcoolique peuple à celui là
s'est employé à faire respecter
et là bonjour la distanciation pourrait
profiter car même vous regardez pas fait
pas bonjour monsieur
bonne fille est elle enfin a suivi les
enfants à leur retour à l'école au jour
des enfants
dans plusieurs coins de france voici ces
députés qui au temps du confinement ont
réinventé leurs fonctions
philippe chalumeau et députée d'indre et
loire
mais avec l'épidémie de cornet virus il
a repris sa sacoche de médecins chaque
après midi à tours le médecin
généraliste va travailler dans un centre
de consultation dédiés ou kovy de 19h
sur blood l'habillage est primordial
pour éviter tout risque de contamination
après son élection en 2017 le docteur
chalumeau officiait encore comme
généraliste environ une journée par
semaine depuis la mi mars
le député rpt devenu médecin presque à
plein temps réputé ce moment-là et mais
ça c'est mon métier
donc voilà je souhaite je souhaite être
utile
c'était intéressant à la fournir les
deux les deux casquettes si j'ose dire
c'est que ça permet d'aborder deux sur
le terrain au plus près et puis de faire
remonter des problèmes actifs
directement et laisser trouver de
solution le matin philippe chalumeau
fait des visites dans un ehpad des
environs l'après midi ils consultent ici
dans cette zone réservée aux patients
qui ont des symptômes de coronavirus
d'accord dont vous êtes aides soignants
ok d'accord et est ce que vous avez
qu'est ce que vous avez comme signe
particulier ce que vous ressentez de la
fia là combien 38,9 mal à la tête
un peu essoufflé pour le moment pas de
pénurie de matériel voilà on va faire un
test parce que ça comme vous travaillez
dans le dans le secteur de la santé a
donc c'est important que vous soyez vous
vous soyez testé pour qu'on sache si
c'est positif ou pas ici les médecins
peuvent réaliser 150 à 200 dépistage par
jour ce patient a une partie des
symptômes ducobu de 19 il ne sera pas
testé car ils ne présentent pas
d'antécédents cardiaques ou
respiratoires avait quand même tous les
signes je suis effectivement curieuse
quand même si le nombre de cas augmente
tour et sa région ne sont pas encore
touchés de plein fouet par l'épidémie
pourtant dans la population l'inquiétude
grandit les doutes aussi pour les
hôpitaux
le rien n'a été prévu ils font tout à
lattes
maintenant chacun se tiendront les
pattes pour savoir si tel ou tel
traitement est efficace ou non
quand le professeur raoul la voyez on
est quand même dans un centre médical
on a tout le matériel le député reprend
vite le dessus sur le médecin quand on a
commencé la crise avait 5000 lits de
réanimation en france aujourd'hui on a
monté on les a montées à dix mille lits
à la récente en bien
mais bon on a regardé les infos ses
projets au lit joly à bas les infos
c'est sûr que c'est pas c'est pas
rassurant
vous savez que monsieur débuté annoncé
jen la prod nous en pensée qui doit
mettre la blouse c'est très bien s'est
il fait preuve d'humanité
il est là pour aider les gens
malgré qu'ils pourraient enfin rester
chéri le député de la majorité reconnaît
néanmoins qu'il faudra tirer les leçons
de cette épidémie
un avant et un après la mort de
l'organisation de notre système de soins
manifestement on s'aperçoit qu'il faut
qu'on faut réparer l'hôpital pour
investir massivement dans l'hôpital ça
c'est très important
on l'avait commencé à le faire en
reprenant 30 % de la dette en voilà en
injectant là en fin d'année ont injecté
un petit peu mais là c'est un plan
massif
il faut pour justement améliorer les
conditions matérielles la journée n'est
pas finie pour philippe chalumeau il
file à son cabinet pour voir tous les
autres malades ceux qui ont besoin de
son même s'ils n'ont pas le corona virus
[Musique]
y'a pas de masque si j'en avais je
n'aurai pas droit de vous les donner
mais je n'en ai pas d'abord la
profession de santé
elle n'a pas hésité une seconde avant de
reprendre son métier de pharmacienne à
temps plein derrière son masque
la député de la 7e circonscription de
seine maritime
agnès firmin le bodo dès le lendemain du
premier tour des élections municipales à
8h30
j'étais dans la pharmacie avec la ferme
intention d'y rester tout au long de la
période nécessaire ça permet aussi
d'abord de prendre la température du
terrain et puis d'être efficace et de
répondre de répondre aux questions et
aux nombreuses sollicitations de nos
clients et les rêves et les
sollicitations sont nombreuses pour la
pharmacienne pour les personnes les plus
fragiles elles seront en personne à leur
domicile leur livrer les médicaments
donc cela est lancé l'idée est là pour
mois prochain en cas de problème si
jamais si jamais vous avez besoin vous
dites est vrai vous apte alors au
complet
c'est sûr que j'apprécie énormément et
puis de toute façon pas seulement là
c'est quelqu'un qui est très à l'éco
tout le temps donc fait partie de la
famille dans le quartier
deux personnes âgées sont décédées du
coït 19 ces derniers jours et agnès
firmin le bodo et souvent en première
ligne qui monsieur minc est décédé
monsieur livré samedi soir est et savoir
que lundi matin il était décédé s'était
ouais c'est toujours un peu compliqué
surtout quand la famille vient vous voir
et cette part de son désarroi
en vous demandant presque en tant que
député si je peux pas intervenir pour
qu'ils sont un peu plus nombreux
assister à l'enterrement et ça c'est
compliqué ça ça fait partie des choses
ou la double casquette est aussi
difficile à gérer parce qu'ils attendent
forcément une réponse une réponse
positive et ma réponse ad forcément que
non même si j'aimerais bien les aider
même si je comprends
l'autre difficulté c'est de fournir de
la solution hydro alcoolique il y un an
la députée avait visité l'usiné si dell
spécialisé dans les machines de
conception de bouteilles plastiques
[Musique]
elle les a recontacté et leur a demandé
de l'aide en urgence
l'entreprise s'est aussitôt mobilisée
pour commencer mais pas de produire des
bouteilles ne veut fabriquer ses
machines dans les bouteilles sont leurs
malentendus par nos clients
c'est donc dans ce cadre nous refusons d
plus de quarante mille flacons qui
seront remplies avec des solutions
hydro-alcooliques distribué en priorité
aux ehpad hôpitaux prisons ou encore
comme ce jour là aux pompiers de 25
embauches à une bande de campeurs
évident donc vous le dis j'ai une fois
on craque la bande d'accord auquel cas
ils sont recyclables
recevez les remerciements du directeur
départemental et de notre chef de
groupement voilà donc déjà et merci
beaucoup de la démarche merci ma côté
martial ou de retour à l'office il la
députée s'éclipse à l'arrière de la
pharmacie déjà avoir senti une
conférence visio avec le bureau de la
commission des affaires sociales donc sa
présidence gilles bourguignon qui ce
matin aurélie pour la continuité des
travaux puisque l'assemblée
les travaux continuent de façon
différente mais pas toujours facile de
jongler entre la pharmacie et le travail
parlementaire mais garder le lien avec
ses collègues de l'assemblée
même en période de confinement est
essentiel pour agnès firmin le bodo
dès qu'ils sortent dans les rues de
sarcelles le député françois pupponi se
sent investi d'une mission faire
appliquer un geste barrière est
essentielle
bonjour la distanciation sociale oui
mais pour qu'ils s'écartent même vous
regardez vers tétouan un médecin quand
un médecin quand à mettre 50 ses murs à
la mi mai pouces soit encore un peu à le
val d'oise comme la seine saint denis
voisine est un territoire vulnérables
face aux covin 19 françois pupponi a été
maire de sarcelles pendant vingt ans il
connaît par coeur le mode de vie des
habitants
on est dans un endroit très dense avec
un habitat collectif important avec des
gens qui cohabitent en nombre important
dans les mêmes logements dans des petits
logements et donc la cohabitation est
plus importante et donc les gens ont
besoin de sortir les jeunes en
particulier
et puis après il ya un autre phénomène
c'est que c'est des populations souvent
des communautés qui ont l'habitude de
vivre dehors parce que c'est leur mode
culturel et donc le confinement est
resté à l'intérieur c'est encore plus
compliqué on a voté la loi
on est là pour on est des élus de la
république c'est ensemble qu'on doit
faire en sorte de gagner cette bataille
et je pense que le rôle d'un élu c'est
en respectant les gestes barrière
effectué dans la mesure du possible
confie demande d'être aussi sur le
terrain pour expliquer aux concitoyens
ce qui va se passer
ce travail sur le terrain le député ne
le mène pas ce monsieur le directeur de
la commisaire messieurs bonjour ça va ça
fait du val d'oise organise tous les
lundis une conférence téléphonique avec
les services de l'état dont le directeur
départemental de sécurité publique
la rs le directeur de l'éducation
nationale et les parlementaires et donc
ça nous permet de passer des messages
j'avais dit voilà autour de la gare de
sarcelles il ya quelque chose à faire
tout de suite la police a réagi des
opérations étaient montés effectivement
devant la gare les policiers viennent
souvent en nombre contrôler les papiers
d'identité et surtout les attestations
de déplacement vous allez recevoir
l'amendé 135 euros
sortir avec une attestation de déflation
dérogatoire rendait toujours qui est
valable quand votre attestation n'est
plus valable sur deux répéteurs n'est
d'accord vous comprenez ou pas je ne
vais pas sortir de chez vous et pendant
ce temps le député continue de faire un
peu la police à sa façon les patrice pas
mal vivre au brésil mais je vais lui
demander on verra après ok mon ami
allait pakistan gelabale il fait partie
de la communauté pakistanaise est
l'objet et donc c'est une communauté qui
a du mal à respecter localement la donc
j'essaie de lui expliquer qu'il faut
qu'il dise à tout le monde de rentrer à
la maison
le député ne limite pas son action à
l'espace public
il n'hésite pas à rentrer dans les
barres d'immeubles derrière ces fenêtres
la réalité du confinement est souvent
difficile
aminata doit s'occuper seule de ses cinq
enfants
la promiscuité commence à peser c'est
difficile à moi j'aimerais bien qu'il
sera soit une ville comme ça les gens
mais c'est vrai quand il fait chaud
comme ça on descend avec qui joue face
aux députés
la mère de famille aborde un sujet très
discuté dans l'immeuble le déconfinement
pour savoir qu'est ce que ça va passer
après parce qu'on sait paquet sa marine
4 le matin j'étais l'assemblée de magie
retour ils sont en train de tout
organiser pour faire en sorte qu'elles
se passent bien
après faut espérer que ça se passe bien
mais il faut après on peut il faut
retourner à la fois à l'école au travail
il faut pour les espérons que la santé
ça est mieux là ça a l'air de baisser un
peu on passe sa sélection d'un fils qui
les installent et et l'éduquer
m'étonnerait qu'on filme à c'est fini
j'espère que tout le monde marque de
luxe toll d'acier
françois pupponi le constate chaque jour
ces cités de banlieue n'ont pas du tout
était pensé pour affronter une telle
pandémie
la crise du coc vide entraînera aussi
une réflexion sur l'urbanisme notamment
en ile de france
[Musique]
c'est devenu un rituel depuis le début
du confinement chaque mercredi le député
richard ramos se rend chez l'oréal situé
dans sa circonscription du loiret donc
là on va rentrer dans l'atelier qui est
produit des fondements et des vernis à
ongles habituellement face à la crise
cette grande entreprise de cosmétiques
s'est tout de suite adapté
bonjour dorénavant ici on produit des
milliers de tubes de gel hydroalcoolique
semaine après semaine la récolte est
bonne voie la voie 1 2 lui c'est bien on
récupérera un peu de bidons et puis
après on se réorganise ramer pour la
tournée d'aujourd'hui les petits les
petits tubes qui sont là j'ai la chance
d'en avoir 40 nous donc ya pas un
habitant de la circonscription
aujourd'hui bien pas un n'aurait pas eu
de gel voilà le nouveau combat de
richard ramos un gel hydroalcoolique
accessible à tous l'occasion aussi de
prendre le pouls de voir comment on vit
le confinement dans cette
circonscription à deux visages
[Musique]
d'abord le côté ville le député modem a
hérité d'une partie d'orléans la
cathédrale mais aussi une banlieue
populaire
premier arrêt de sa longue tournée le
quartier de l'argonne
bon allez on est parti à plat la
distanciation et plutôt bien respecté
dans cette files d'attentes
ici comme dans tout le département du
loiret on est relativement épargnée par
l'épidémie
le problème c'est surtout de supporter
le confinement tu allais aussi dans des
maisons dans les appartements il y avait
sept huit enfants dans des petits
appartements et c'est pas la même chose
et puis ils sortent dehors parce que ici
d'habitude ici il ya plein de noms des
chibanis les anciens sont sur les bancs
qui sont derrière la ja personnes et les
gamins on va se faire peut être contrôlé
par la police
[Musique]
et puis dans la circonscription de
richard ramos
il y a aussi le côté chant des terres
agricoles des villages ici les rues sont
plus calmes la vie plus lente
loin du brouhaha de la ville mais
également à plus de 30km de l'hôpital le
plus proche
alors c'est l'infirmière libérale qui
prend le relais or un peuple voilà
toutes les semaines rendez vous sur ce
parking
c'est le député qui lui fournit son gel
mylène soigne plusieurs cas de co vide
elle se sent aujourd'hui laissés pour
compte
on a besoin vraiment de tout le matériel
comme comme les patients les gens qui
suivent les passions kovy devant servir
à quoi
et les ouais on est oubliés parce que là
on n'entend parler que les infirmières
des pas des infirmières de pete auront
touché 1500 euros enfin disons que nous
notre salaire là je sais même pas moi
personnellement si je vais réussir à
mettre 1000 euros de mon sac de salaire
ce mois ci quand j'avais senti
l'inquiétude
[Musique]
richard ramos poursuit sa tournée des
petits villages plus de rendez vous la
vie mais la distribution se fait ici à
lui même à la criée pour aller déjà je
voulais un peu à du g1 corps du gène et
quelques masques ce couple de 85 ans et
producteur d' asperges peu de voisins
ici mais quand même beaucoup
d'appréhension face au virus
et qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ce
que 8,19 de communes la guerre mais oui
l'occupation et non c'était quand même
c'était trop tard ces paramètres peuvent
tout compte fait c'est quoi la peur
aujourd'hui tout dans un mona hraoui
réaménagé et peuget peu la frousse et
puis ça me travaille je suis je suis à
peu essoufflées
ouais donc faut faire attention là et
attention oui comment
jaf on reste à 1 m je vais ici une
demi-heure fais mes courses se jouent au
public au pas et puis dans ces coins de
campagne il y a ceux qui tiennent à
garder leur humour et regarde pas la
même pour tous à mes abonnés parce que
c'est du clandestin à la cour marini
petit village de 330 habitants le maire
75 ans l'admets
difficile de bouleverser son quotidien
celui-là tous les lots je circule tous
les jours et je vais voir les copains
tous les jours les jeunes chanteurs
frais à mes amis me confine pas rempli
son trait mais c'est ce que je dis
souvent la réalité c'est que c'est la
réalité c'est autre chose
enfin en hausse à ramos a écoulé ses
bouteilles de gênes fin de la mission
jusqu'au mercredi suivant bonjour
monsieur bonjour les filles
cette rentrée un peu spécial la députée
béatrice descamps aurait pu la vivre
comme directrice d'école le métier
qu'elle exerçait il y encore quatre
alors ses premiers jours se sont bien
passées très très très très honnêtement
sont ravis de reprendre l'école vous
permet de reprendre et que les gars sont
ils tout se passe bien
la vie reprend un peu le cours des
choses
une nouvelle façon de vous deux yeux 1
mais on s'adapte si la députée a décidé
de replonger dans le bain scolaire c'est
qu'elle est investi d'une mission bien
particulière elle copréside à
l'assemblée un groupe chargé d'évaluer
le déconfinement dans les écoles
j'ai essayé pendant toute cette période
de travail de groupe de toujours garder
anja à vous avec les écoles ou avec les
mairies par mail par téléphone
aujourd'hui je suis contente de pouvoir
venir voir comment se passe dans une
école de ce type parce que bon voilà ici
nous sommes à la campagne et qu'une
petite école
rombies et marchipont un village de 760
habitants près de valenciennes dans la
circonscription de béatrice descamps
l'école accueille en temps normal 88
enfants de maternelle et de primaire
fermée durant le confinement
elle a rouvert ses portes deux jours
plus tôt bonjour peut se permettre
bonjour les enfants est alors moi je
suis béatrice descamps et aujourd'hui je
viens dans votre école parce que vous
avez repris l'école récemment après une
longue période à la maison et l'école
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec ce
qu'elle était avant
dans cette classe six enfants seulement
de trois niveaux différents de la toute
petite section au ce2
quel que soit l'âge le programme cette
semaine c'est surtout l'apprentissage
des gestes barrières quand on chante on
parle virus ou encore quand on colorie
on dessine microbes
et pour les plus petits il vaut mieux ne
pas se tromper quand on choisit son jeu
il n'y en aura qu'un seul donc forcément
ce qui est différent c'est qu'on n'est
pas tous sur la même table à se partager
les utilisent la leur mais voilà ils
utilisent leur matériel et paris
spécifiquement pour chacun d'entre eux
c'est ça les enfants n'ont plus le droit
de se toucher ni même de jouer entre eux
le premier objectif pour béatrice
descamps c'est de voir si les enfants
vont bien
après cette longue période sans école
est ce que tu es revenu parce que tes
parents travaillent ou parce que tu t'es
vraiment envie de les parents c'est de
revenir en janvier vous avez d'ailleurs
très bien que tu t'appelais une jolie
écriture de long une jolie l'écriture tu
étais content quand tes parents tandis
que tu revenais à l'école non et
maintenant ça se passe bien oui sauf que
les copains thomas
on mais je suis persuadé qu'ils vont
revenir l'école et la mairie s'étaient
organisés pour qu'une cinquantaine
d'élèves puissent être accueillis
seulement 16 ont répondu à l'appel la
directrice
aurais tu aimé en avoir plus et surtout
une douzaine d'entre vous on aimerait
quand même voir revenir vers nous les
enfants qui ont des grandes difficultés
qui sont en grande difficulté scolaire
c'est comme sont quand même ces
enfants-là qui serait préférable
d'accueillir parce que eux à distance
c'est que ça reste très très compliqué
de de pouvoir leur transmettre parce
qu'il à transmettre
voilà si ces familles là ne sont pas
forcément revenus eux les impros
ici l'enjeu est donc de gagner la
confiance des parents pour que les
enfants reviennent pas trop nombreux
quand même
l'école ne pourra pas accueillir ses 88
élèves le maire élu depuis 19 ans
aimerait bien avoir plus de visibilité
est ce qu'il y aura des pauses des
possibilités des éventualités de
changement décès d'ici la fin la fin de
mer en eau soit ou vraiment l'on aura
sans doute à bhl plus grand nombre
d'enfants
moi je pense avec la reprise du travail
pratiquement pour tout le monde
moi je pense que ça peut évoluer que
tous les enfants sont à l'école une fois
c'est le souhait du monde de l'éducation
nationale vous pensez que c'est tout
neuf
non je n'y crois pas malheureusement non
moi je dis malheureusement parce que je
pense que pour certains ce serait
vraiment bien comme les 13 autres
députés de son groupe de travail
béatrice descamps va poursuivre les
visites
le groupe devrait remettre un rapport au
ministre de l'éducation nationale
avec le déconfinement l'assemblée a
rouvert ses portes
les députés ont repris une vie normale
entre hémicycle et circonscription
jusqu'à la courte trêve de l'été
[Musique]